foreign
John where'd you grow up where are you
from originally I grew up in San Pedro
California
tell me about your family
uh my parents were married until I was
five years old
they're uh one is
hard right wing the other one is hard
left wing but they share a love of
arguing so I grew up with that yeah and
uh it was perfect for that but um
they divorced the nose five and uh
my older sister and my younger brother
and I used to uh we got along great for
the most part but we used to brawl all
the time getting these huge fights
but uh it was the kind of dynamic where
you know if anybody else messed with us
then you know you Team Up We're Not
Gonna We're not gonna have it yeah
so um I think it was I had loving
parents and loving grandparents for as
much as they knew how to do you know how
far did you go in school
uh just before passing high school and
then I took the GED later
and drugs came into your life at some
point
uh yes when I was
actually my stepbrother my mom and my
stepdad uh met because me and my
stepbrother were best friends in uh
kindergarten he's my age he died last
year of a fentanyl overdose actually
sorry and um
uh I forget where I was going with this
I'm sorry
um
I guess
oh yeah so my friends and I he and my
friend Frank and I would experiment a
little bit we'd smoke weed or drink
alcohol and
you know I still remember the first time
I took a drink and I felt that warm
feeling in my stomach and I had all this
confidence with girls and
I just felt like everything was all
right and it blew my mind that something
you could buy off a shelf would have
that effect you know
and you stuck with it
yeah I decided that that's how I wanted
to live my life
so today you're using
which drug
uh fentanyl Fentanyl
where'd you stay
on the streets right now I'm about to go
into a mission I think
um
I've been on and off opioids for about
11 years
you've been homeless for how long uh
about a year and a half
uh in and out of jail
and um
so yeah a girl a girl introduced me to
opioids which I was never really going
to have in my life I can't blame it on
her but uh
you know I kept saying get it out of my
house I don't want drugs in my house
even though I was smoking weed and
drinking all day
and so uh one day I tried it out and I
thought you know this stuff doesn't
really do that much it just kind of
makes you feel good
I don't see where the stigma is
and so I kept doing it and about two
weeks later I ran out
and uh I had what seemed to be the worst
flu of my life I was shivering I was
freezing cold I was throwing up
everywhere
I couldn't move but I couldn't not move
I was it was horrifying and so for
five or six days I didn't sleep when I
came off that first time
and uh
yeah that was my first kick and um
a lot of people have told me that uh
oh if the kick is so bad why do you keep
going back to it it's like well because
I mean quite frankly it's the way you
want to feel when you're living life I
believe
uh when I was younger I asked a friend
of mine who had tried heroin what it was
like
and the answer he told me was perfect he
said uh you know when you have to wake
up really early in the morning and it's
freezing cold and it's dark out
and uh the floor is cold and you just
don't want to get out of bed he says you
know how your bed feels
he says that's what heroin feels like
and that's actually the perfect
comparison I think
have you you're aware of How It's I
guess you'd credit the drug is kind of
taking your life apart though
absolutely and uh
it was one of the toughest struggles
I can't say it's the toughest Circle A
person can go through because I know
people go through crazy struggles and
make it out the other end but um
uh when you're off of it it feels like
you're drowning
like it feels like you're no longer
thinking logically and rationally about
this is what I need to do in order for
my life to get better you're just
thinking like I need air I need air I
need air
and anything standing between you and
air is standing between you and air you
know yeah
and eventually you find the drug again
and you're
yeah
and uh
I've hurt the people I love a lot and I
feel horrible for you know
not physically hurt them but just the
type of things where I I don't think
they can be really ever fully taken back
you know
or repair even though I'd like to
how old are you
I'm 37 37. you have kids no no kids
you've been in love before
yes very soon
uh
and actually the most the most recent
time I was in love was in my heroin
addiction
was in and out of it I kept getting
sober and
relapsing but uh
she's a gorgeous amazing girl and uh she
was smart and funny and we got along
great and had great chemistry and
uh but I would just turn into a kind of
zombie
and uh at the same time I would start
you know just doing seedy things
spending all the money without telling
her
I would start stealing things
uh sneaking out in the middle of the
night to go get what I needed
um
and uh she took me back a lot of times
and actually this last time my biggest
question on my mind is wondering whether
it's
I'd like to go back to her but I don't
know if it's morally right for me to do
that you know what I mean
you hurt her
yeah she's going back she's going
through a lot and I don't know whether
it would be right of me to uh
to
put her through even more you know
so uh
yeah that's where I'm at with that if
you had your life to live all over again
what would you have done differently
foreign
you know I think I would just learn to
be content wherever I happened to be in
the world and make things work from
there because I've never been content
and a lot of people at meetings will say
that they felt the same way like they
just feel like um
there's just something eating at him all
the time
and the first time they take that drink
or the drug that it it
takes off that feeling for the first
time you've never
you never knew how much it weighed until
you had it taken off
and um
the last time I was sober I was really I
was working on that because you know
things are pretty
things are very intense when you're
newly sober again
it's like being a teenager and going
right into high school again for the
first time just everything is just loud
and intense
are you supporting yourself now
uh boosting
I've heard it so many times you get into
behaviors that I assume are not part of
who you would be normally if you weren't
on drugs yeah because that's not you're
not a thief no no
I take pride in being able to uh
pull my own weight
in fact this last time I was in
treatment I I was saying that a lot to
the people there I'm like I want to get
to a point in my life where I can pull
my own weight and feel like I have a
reason to wake up in the morning
and uh feel like my life is worth
something because I've invested
something into it
not that I'm just sitting in groups all
day or whatever they have you doing
there
what's the emotional toll that this
takes on you
oh it takes a variety of them
I mean you can look at it from the
outside and say Here's all the tragedy
that came from it
and here are all the things that could
have been avoided
and um
I know there's that
and then every time you go back into it
there's like this whole new kind of
sinking feeling that comes from like why
did I just do this again now everybody I
know is going to know this
and
and at this point I'm kind of like I
don't even really disappoint myself
anymore I'm sad that I disappoint the
people that I love because they don't
deserve it you know
and that was such a difficult drug to
break free from right
it really is
and you would think that once you're
and I always truly thought that once
you're past the actual withdrawal period
you know you don't sleep for like eight
days and I mean you do not sleep for
eight days and you're squirming around
and you can't hold any food down and
you're just in the this dark depression
have you made it eight days
oh yeah I've made it through it most
mostly in jail though
but uh
after that
still for whatever reason every now and
then there will come a time when it's
just like
the thought enters your head you don't
push it right out and you just roll with
it
and kind of uh once you flip that switch
you can't unflip it
for me anyway like I can't make the
decision okay you know maybe it's
possible for me to do this and get away
with it one more time
like once I say that
like I'm gonna do it there's no there's
no stopping me from doing it
and uh that's one of the hard Parts I
feel for me to get over because
it's uh it's ended badly multiple times
because it's just that
a random decision one day yeah
do you have friends now yeah
yeah
people on the streets or actual like
friends from before both and now I'm
having a hard time uh I haven't talked
to my friends from um treatment for a
while
uh I was visiting one of my friends in
the hospital for a while she's back home
now
haven't seen her since I relapsed
uh one of my other friends he's he's
doing great and I'm happy for him but he
doesn't know that I am where I am right
now and I'm afraid to say anything
because
it's a
like these people have been good friends
to me and I don't want to even have
ammunition to say oh well now they're
not good friends because they're not
there for me when I need them I don't I
don't even want to be able to say that
because I know I'll just let it trick me
into
making another bad choice you know
do you think it's a better chance of you
getting clean and getting free from this
or
staying deeper in it and potentially
even dying
the possibility of death has become a
lot closer to me this last time than it
has any other time you've ided before Oh
yeah and the past four days are probably
OD'd six times really yeah like almost
died like turn blue and everything and
uh
that's never happened before
I always kind of had this thought that I
would never die I would just you know
some convenient I think would always
happen I'd always make it through the
other side like I always have why
shouldn't I you know
but this last couple of times has only
been by acts of God that I've actually
lived through something as simple as a
doing a little bit of Fentanyl
taking one puff off a piece of foil and
it's particularly strong and I just hit
the ground head first and that's it
and even going through that and having
gratitude for like surviving that
still isn't enough to get you to
to quit well on a larger sense it is but
I mean
kind of like a lot of people stay in
abusive relationships because right now
it's not bad enough to have to leave
it's kind of like that like uh
on a larger scale yeah that's a great
reason but uh in the immediate here and
now it's not enough to pull me out of it
and go through all the
you know all the horrors I got to go
through to get back out of it again
and I know that what I got coming is
going to be difficult
you know almost no matter what
but uh
I don't know I don't know what you do
make the best of it
um
I I don't know how to handle this part I
never have
so I guess I'm just hoping for the best
John what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
in my life
I think the most important lesson I've
learned in my life is to
Do no harm
uh
you're a million times when I've wished
I could get revenge on somebody for
screwing me over in some petty way and
the very few times that's actually
happened it's always ended up feeling
horrible and I've ended up feeling
really bad about it didn't feel like a
victory
and uh
yeah I don't want to hurt my family I
don't want to hurt my friends and I'm
like if it takes me taking a kick every
now and then I'm cool with that
I just don't want to be somebody who
goes out hurting people
I don't want to be the type of person
who people see and they're like oh yeah
he's a crazy selfish [ __ ] you know
all right John thank you so much for
sharing your story
wish you lots of luck thank you